[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'avais dit au photographe on fait
quelque chose de très simple très
spectacle qui dit juste vous allez
prendre votre pied pendant deux heures
au début je me suis dit c'est très joli
et puis je l'ai montré à ma sœur elle
m'a dit mais tu es au courant que
normalement dans les trous ce sont pas
des micro
statistiques j'ai perdu 0,1% de mon
public à cause du covid principalement
des personnes âgées et des personnes en
surpoids le public dans les salles de
spectacle c'est un petit peu comme les
nuages dans le ciel moi il y a de gros
mais on voit
et depuis Mitou j'ai vu des mecs
remettre en question toute leur
existence je l'ai violé la voisine en 92
où elle était consentante ah c'est
toujours difficile à dire avec cette
tétraplégique
trisomique s'en allait tout défaillant
ah la sécu de Rouen pris toutes les
allocations et ma grand-mère lue dans le
fion elle mourra seule sans un rond
alors j'étais voir un petit peu sur des
vlogs féministes pour me renseigner il
est impératif que le consentement soit
réitérer à chaque étape du rapport après
pour la préservation de l'espèce
j'espère quand même qu'il reste des
violeurs parce que moi un mec qui me
demande mon consentement à chaque coup
de [ __ ] je reste pas jusqu'à la fin
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]